[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar improving protein expression in
e coli b strains using rapid genome
engineering
i am cayley bach of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by inscripta to learn more please
visit inscripta.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
tyson shepard phd microbial engineering
applications manager at inscripta dr
shepard you may now begin your
presentation
good morning thank you so much for
joining us for this morning's webinar um
so
i'm a senior scientist and applications
manager at inscripta
and today i'm going to be talking to you
about applying the inscriptive platform
technology with its capabilities of
rapid genome engineering to improve the
expression of the e coli b strains so as
you probably know that the e coli b
strains are a go-to resource for the uh
hydraulics expression of of proteins
and here we thought uh wouldn't it be
interesting if we could apply the
genome engineering capacities the rapid
and high throughput capacities of the
onyx platform
to be able to investigate variants of
that
of those b strains that could improve
production of uh of of proteins and so
that's the story that i'm going to tell
you about today
so as you are all probably aware
hydraulic is protein production is
forming sort of the the cornerstone of
the the entire building of of a bio
based economy
uh and we see this happening throughout
a number of different
areas within society that are being
completely transformed
over the modern era with the
capabilities of
that come along for dna synthesis and
rapid dna and cost-effective dna
sequencing
so this has been a long time coming but
we're seeing
brand new capacities being built within
industrial biotechnology for improving
uh fuel production in a in a green way
being able to degrade waste streams and
create valuable commodity chemicals from
those uh from those waste streams and
and
generate new dyes and new concretes and
all sorts of fantastic things that are
coming from industrial biotechnology
um when we look at
other
areas we
you're probably aware of
the alternative protein productions that
come from
synthesis
uh to make uh what's can be called lab
grown meats or um
proteins that would
synthesize the experience of eating
meats in that flavor profile and
nutritional quality
uh
the
other
um
another fields of interest is
the the impact of synthetic biology on
agriculture
so that comes in the in the form of you
know you can think about nitrogen uh
fixation uh for certain plants as well
as uh being able to engineer better
micro a microbiome for improved crop
yields
or a generation of insecticidal proteins
there's number of
very cool applications that are being
built within agriculture and then of
course in
the the final one i have listed here is
in biopharma and therapeutic production
and that comes from the fact you can
think of in living medicines the
capabilities of um
having at the site generation of
therapeutics and then also
um therapeutics being produced within e
coli itself or yeast or human cells
uh and those
um
[Music]
span the gamut from enzyme replacement
therapy through generation of
specific antibodies
so um all of this is is being built on
the aspect that we can do rapid
engineering of host cells
and these microbial cell factories are
that production element that's necessary
for um for advancing all of these
industries
but when we think about the problem of
hydraulics protein expression there's
usually a few challenges along the way
when we set out for improved protein
production what we're realistically
looking for at the end of the day
is improved yields of functional enzymes
or proteins and improve
purity of those uh proteins and there's
a number of headwinds that are uh facing
us when we look at that yield and purity
profile uh for getting improvements and
those might come from low expression uh
of the protein of interest
uh the protein may be uh have uh
solubility issues or um problems with uh
forming inclusion bodies that would
precipitate out of solution
and be inaccessible
um for for subsequent refolding let's
say uh certainly degradation is an issue
with the
presence of proteases especially upon
lysis and e coli
and then we think about
the toxicity profile frequently that
comes with e coli that it that has uh
endotoxins that have to be removed that
can be costly for
uh for that removal uh proteins can also
become misfolded if not
if it requires a specialized chaperone
or growing conditions um and
and then of course you know the the
ultimate form is the active protein of
interest or active enzyme and we may
have inactivity due to any number of
other problems uh
so
there's a number of you know all of
these headwinds come about uh and
getting us to think well uh how do you
overcome those as as the state of the
art um and
ultimately what it comes down to and and
what i'm going to propose to you is that
it's all
for the most part all of these uh can be
overcome by uh scalable host strain
engineering to meet the demands of the
protein that's being produced uh so that
host strain engineering means um what
type of modifications can you do to the
chassis or the
the e coli or the yeast uh to be able to
improve the expression of an otherwise
uh a protein that that would not be
happy uh being produced in its current
circumstance
um
so when we think through uh the actual
production of the protein
usually it's uh it comes down to a
number
or a thought process that the individual
takes when
generating the the the vinyl protein so
that can be in the form of how to create
the actual construct itself with the
promoters uh the gene itself and that
optimization of the coding sequence
which terminators to use
what does the structure look like are
there any modifications that you might
want to build into it
should i be integrating this into the
genome or should i be present
producing it off of plasmids
these are type of these are the type of
thought processes that go into the
specific
target gene of interest that you're
looking at and then there's the uh sort
of the next step of thinking about is
what host cell do i want to use uh so as
i mentioned a go-to host cell within the
the community is of course um
is
like b strains like bl 21 for example
that might be your your first go-to
uh
so you might want to express it due to
chaperones or
due to translation due to glycosylation
you may prefer yeast for example or
or a variant thereof or you may need to
go all the way to human cells in order
to allow for that
there's a number of different varieties
of host cells that i'm going to talk
about in a few minutes
and so that's not an inconsequential
decision when you think through of what
your whole cell looks like
and then at the end
you grow up your whole cell in some type
of media so you're thinking about the
media and you're thinking um in terms of
how to get that purification
uh so that might be might want to
introduce fusion tags
into it you're probably looking for a
very specific amount of
uh the
protein of interest
looking specifically at uh
you know what confounding factors are
there such as endotoxin
levels can you secrete the protein
rather than having it internal to the
cell
and avoid lysis etc um and then finally
you have your purified protein that's
where
oftentimes a lot of us in the audience
think that that's you know you you've
reached something exciting then once you
have the purified protein you can test
its activity and and um its capabilities
and so that's what we want to get to is
as quickly as possible ultimately is
that purified protein that we can take
downstream for structure activity
relationships or
functional uh activities uh this and and
new discoveries
so we want
um to make that you know an easier
process because right now uh the state
of the art
is there's a number of different uh
strains when you think of like for b
strain production of of proteins in
bl-21s for example and and derivatives
uh these are often the strains that you
go to for protein production
and there's some very good reasons for
going to these strains so bl21 um has a
lawn
and umptee proteases it's deficient in
these proteases so you're gonna have
improved
uh yields and less degradation uh b
strains themselves have an improved atp
utilization uh
possibly are principally due to the fact
that they're uh
non-motel and and so that atp resource
can be diverted to greater protein
production it also has reduced acetate
during protein production so there's a
number of reasons for
bl-21s being valued for protein
production over k strain so that's the
alternative that's what we um
we've talked a great deal about that in
previous webinars with utilization of
case strains where you're thinking more
in terms of cloning and genomic
discovery
here it's more about hardens protein
production
is a go-to resource for these so when
you're thinking about basic protein
production there's that bl21 de3s if
it's a toxic protein you might want the
peli s in there
there's uh pet plasmids is your go-to
resource for production uh typically
with the t7 polymerase on that de3
lysogen that allows for production
off a t7 promoter and then you do some
moderate condition screening with
different media types as well as
different temperature of induction
different flasks
and so forth these are kind of the basic
or first rounds
details on on looking at that but often
uh we'll want um expression of proteins
let's say have a human codon bias
associated with them the e coli is not
going to like that so we might want to
diversify our strains a little bit so we
go back to our freezer we might pull out
the rosettas or bl21d3 stars that have
these capacities for
different profiles of codon usage we
might want tunable expression that's
where we go for with the p-bads
plasmids and um then we might start to
get a little bit more elaborate as we
get to the skilled production when we're
thinking about auto induction media and
scaling it to a bioreactor production
there's been an extra kind of you know
step beyond that these are special i
call them specialty strains so when i
think of uh but but but they're
fantastic in their own rights and so
what i think of uh for specialty strains
is if there's a toxic protein in
particular then you might go for c41s
if you want disulfide bonds you might
reach for the origami string or the
shuffle strain
there's elaborate vector
building capacities with golden gate
cloning or a bio brick or bagel brick
cloning and then of course your
conditions can get more elaborate too
with scaling up the bioreactors to
thousands of liters with defined media
and a batch fed system so all of this is
uh reviewed elegantly in the i list one
paper here it's reviewed elegantly in
multiple different papers
um
there's a there's a
a bl21 variant in particular
bl21 has a
filamentation like uh phenotype so that
it can form extensive filaments uh if
under the right conditions uh and uh nab
has an nab express a b strain that's
capable of producing protein
with that filamentation defect removed
such that they maintain a
non-filamentous
morphology to them
and that's what i'll be talking about in
part today as well
um
so yeah because of this diversity you
know we we have these in our freezer
boxes we probably when we're expressing
proteins if if we really like expressing
in in b strains we're gonna go and we're
gonna test probably
you know five ten different variants of
e coli but what if i was to tell you
that it might be possible that you could
go to your freezer and
pull out and test ten thousand different
variants at the same time and identify
variants that improve the expression of
your protein in a very high throughput
way and that's where the magic of the uh
in inscription
platform comes in so in script it has
this uh
solution for crispr based editing where
um historically in crispr based editing
you think of in terms of a per well
editing such that each well would have
introduced to it a glide rna or some dna
encoding a guide rna and then introduce
also the homology repair template to be
able to make that modification but what
the enscript onyx platform is finally
fundamentally based on is the
introduction of a plasmid that contains
the guide rna the homology repair
template or the donor and a trackable
barcode that doesn't get integrated into
the genome and rests on an external
plasmid that can be maintained
throughout the entire expression process
to be able to identify variants of
interest in a high throughput method
so
that trackable barcode is um is then in
this plasmids this underlies uh and is
fundamentally based on on what's called
create
plasmid technology that's been well
cited
and
so we built an automated platform to be
able to do this
uh so to get to the point of developing
a method for high throughput generation
of variants of e coli and yeast uh we
built out an onyx platform to be able to
address
anywhere from very specific um down to a
100 edits um single edits per cell but
100 different edits in your pool
where you might have very specific
knockouts that you might want to make
and analyze
very specific uh promoter insertions
you might you know
have some idea from literature searches
and so forth what to do with
in terms of pathway engineering so you
might want to hit certain pathways and
be able to
to perturb certain pathways to see how
they help in your protein expression
project
and you have the capacity of being able
to do protein engineering so um think of
like massive site-directed mutagenesis
capacities with barcode trackability
what that barcode trackability means is
that every variant that you've generated
is now accessible through that barcode
which is something that is not
accessible with protein engineering on
plasmids
and then as you think more broadly
there's all the great stuff that we know
about pathways and then there's all the
stuff that we don't know about genomes
and that's where genome discovery and
genome engineering comes in and that's
also capable of being accomplished with
the
same onyx platform this automated
platform of being able to do genome-wide
knockouts and geno-wide promoter
insertions that give this
capability of discovering all those
unknown variables uh that can improve uh
expression of a protein
so fundamentally that's uh in script
onyx the box has uh is based on a mad
seven um
crispr based nucleus at nuclease uh to
do targeted editing uh in any given run
we can do from 100 to 10 000 different
variants um designs within a single tube
that's still single edit per cell
but each of those edits are then
trackable uh we have a diverse edit
edit types that can be made from
deletions to insertions and
substitutions up to 63 base pairs in
length
and then we can go
[Music]
gene
centric and do saturation mutagenesis
all the way to being able to do gene and
wide editing um and and then it's left
to the
to the
creation of the researcher to be able to
carry that
to to to higher expression
so the total platform is um
comes at the the entire uh
iterating allowing for the iteration of
the giant design generate test and learn
cycle to go much more rapidly um and
that all starts at an inscriptive
designer it's an easy to use portal to
be able to engineer a microbial genome
uh it's a lot like you know you you get
to make edits um computationally in very
high throughput and be able to see the
impact of those edits on this elegant
designer
uh you you know click submit and two to
three weeks later you receive a
consumables kit that gets loaded to an
automated instrument
you press go on the instruments it's
hands off for the next
two or three days it's working to
generate your
library containing all of your designs
of interest
once the door opens up the two or three
days is passed you take the cell output
tube that contains all of those variants
that you generated and now it's up to
the creativity of the researcher to move
forward on those
with uh phenotyping and so you get to
pick uh colonies look for a screeners
workflow or you can do a selector's
workflow
at the end of the day this all goes back
to the sequencer where you can read up
those barcodes of the whole genome
sequencing
and then you can push that back up to
the software that has an automated
capability of analyzing the results and
so it's really acting as a as a
kind of collaborator for you for your
entire workflow uh to learn new things
about
the improvements that can be made with
your organism
and then feed those right back in and
continuously cycle through to get those
type of improvements
so as i briefly mentioned there's two
different workflows that we uh nearly
always go through with those edited
cells we take that edited cell pool um
and then we either move forward in an
isolate based screening workflow or in a
pooled base selection workflow um here
you know in in this example i will
mostly be talking about a
screeners-based isolate workflow where
then you take that forwards uh
downstream to
identification of
um higher expression or greater activity
of the enzyme of interest and that might
come through high throughput mass spec
in my case i used a lot of
plate reading just a simple fluorescence
based plate reading
at the end of the day i get some type of
phenotype readouts
from that
and then that goes back to sequencing as
i mentioned to be able to connect that
genotype to the phenotype and that's
really powerful when you think through
the uh capability of being able to
generate that
um that that that relationship to be
able to discover uh new things about
your organism and about the expression
profile and even the mechanism of action
sometimes on how the protein is actually
responding in the cell
um so we have uh now the support for
high efficiency editing in b strains in
e coli so
uh within the last few months we rolled
out the capacity of being able to
support editing within b strain and uh
our supported uh um base strain uh
that's that's distributable is the
inscripted 1022 b strain uh this is
derived from nab express and so we see
high edit uh if
fractions so they they percent edited on
the right i show a table the percent of
the library that was observed uh when
taking just
a small aliquot from the cell output
tube and processing it by sequencing we
see you know nearly 100 percent of the
library is observed on these runs and
the edit fractions are
pretty fantastic i mean this is you know
45 percent of the identified of the
aliquot of cells contain edited cells uh
so the the edit fraction itself is quite
high um we've tested this in a variety
of custom strains as well besides the
nab express
for
d3 type work for where you want that t7
polymerase there's a t7 express
for disulfide bonds we've tested it with
shuffle strain and nab strain as well
and we've also tested it with a number
of bl21 strains uh both from nab as well
as from agilent and novagin
in on all cases tested uh we see
really you know great performance with
the b strain um ends and we're really
excited to be supporting this capacity
now
so i wanted to um talk a little bit
about two stories that we have on
improving hydraulics protein production
with the onyx platform
the first story is actually in
yeast so we've been talking about b
strain uh yeast is another you know
microbe that's the inscriptonix platform
supports uh and is capable of
doing high throughput editing to be able
to uh identify those type of variants
that would improve protein production
so in this case we had an interest in
improving cbh1 production in in yeast um
so cbh1 cell biohydrolase a one uh
degraded cellulose uh or a and is
involved in that pathway um which is
really you know useful for industrial
purposes uh so what we did is we
generated a base strain with uh cbh1
variants um wherein we also put a
specific signal sequence to allow for
its export out of the yeast that we were
using we utilized the sun pk based ring
or parental string that we built this
into
uh
and then we
expressed it with the you know two
promoter and uh
shows a terminator that would also give
high expression so we started with a
pretty good expression cassette already
integrated into the genome um we had a
fluorescence-based assay that worked on
uh sorry the absorbance at 405 to be
able to assay the actual
activity of uh
and give a readout on the amount of
protein that's uh available
and then we executed on a screening
workflow um and so this execution was uh
done by erica batea descripto where uh
he screened through
many many different colonies to be able
to identify variance uh genome variants
that improved expression
what kind of libraries did we use or and
what kind of libraries are we talking
about generating here
so we can go
genome-wide with our libraries or we can
do targeted based approaches with
genome-wide libraries we can think
through
applications
where we would do gene and white
knockouts
for example so knocking out each of the
individual coding sequences
we can go genome-wide and yeast with
terminator insertions that stabilize uh
each of the the proteins through that
stabilizing element on the three prime
utr
we can also go genome-wide
and and make modifications to predicted
promoters to be able to identify how
that might respond to protein production
and then uh
you know we call them genome-wide
because they're usually spread out and
this works in e coli and yeast and we'll
get into this with e coli too is that we
can modify or perturb protease pathways
um and also say glycosylation pathways
in yeast uh to be able to see if those
have any impact and then so this is the
gene wide and then we might think of
targeted libraries and this is a
different philosophy this is targeting
the actual hydrologist sequence that
you've inserted into the genome so as
soon as it's in the genome and can be
carried
carried around in the genome that
becomes accessible to editing
and so we carried out an executor number
of edits libraries that are targeting
the gene specifically itself so
modifying the eno2 promoter for example
by
insertions and deletions of
transcription factor binding sites and
also swapping arounds
binding sites uh we had a library that
modified the signal sequence as well as
the kozak sequence and then a site
saturation library where we were
investigating a novel variants of cbh1
itself so it got really exciting to be
able to automatically generate these
types of libraries where the real fun of
it comes in the phenotyping that comes
off of instrument we can grab those and
do phenotyping and be able to
execute on that right away so that we
can get from conception to reality very
quickly
and what's fascinating is we ran um all
of these screens uh
with you know thousands of colonies even
on those first rule we call the first
round this uh screening gave a number of
different fold improvements over the
base string so it was uh you can see
they're hovering around one but there's
a number of different uh in every case
of all of these libraries that i just
talked through there's a number of
different variants that are hitting at
that 1.5 to twofold improvement already
in that first round of editing
so we're seeing that cbh1 in these
strains is already being overexpressed
so what would happen then if we took all
of those winners all of those uh
fantastic kids recombine them and
generate a new library
uh
and stacked on top of that library and
that's what exactly what eric abbott did
he took those hits he generated a new
genome white knockouts uh and and
different expression variants on top of
that as well as the hits library on top
of that what he saw now is that he's
starting from
uh with all of those you know rich bass
drains that are already working well
he's already starting from that 1.5 to
twofold improvement and now he's going
uh and and getting you know greater than
twofold in richmond almost up to
threefold enrichments of that production
of cbh1
uh and this is iterative arounds on the
on the instrument that that he that he's
executing this on and so this is done
within you know months from the
conception all the way to now getting
greater than two and a half fold
improvement of expression he then took a
further
uh those variants that were really
outperforming from that second rounds
and already he's starting from a high
baseline of about three-fold improvement
on the top hits and then further does
a hits library on top of that where now
he's iterating and he's only taking the
best winners from the first library
stacking on top of that and identifying
those that now he's getting greater than
threefold greater than 3.5 folds
improvement of expression
uh
after just you know iteratively running
uh three rounds on the instrument
looking for um looking for variants
and what's
fascinating about that is that then you
can start pulling out the biology of
those individual variants uh so in total
he ran seven libraries on the first
round and identified 74 hits this was
within three months we identified that
the almost two-fold improvement uh he
iterated on that and identified
improvements
that got him above two-fold improvements
in a month and a half and then he did
that third rounds of editing where he
got that 3.5 fold improvement almost
four-fold improvement in yet another
month and a half so in total
he was able to
improve his protein production by four
folds in
a little less than six months
and when you think through the
downstream uh implications on that on a
bioreactor scale that's an awfully
compelling and interesting argument
about
how much improvement can be made by the
host string modifications
um one of the neat aspects of this is
that although it took that you know
nearly six months this was a very
hands-off workflow in terms of the
actual design and build of these
libraries uh you know this was uh
and oftentimes the enscripted designer
is is automated and funded it's so fun
to work with that you know it doesn't
seem like hardly any time is spent at
all at the designer um and then you it's
that push button go to to generate the
actual libraries um so ultimately this
is very few ftes to be able to get this
level of improvements in this amount of
time
so we wondered hypothetically could we
apply the same philosophy towards b
string production and that's where uh
this workflow came in on how we might be
able to edit the b string to improve
production
so
um our target you know our first round
target was uh was a a
a protein of an enzyme of interest to
both therapeutic purposes as well as a
bioindustrial enzyme
so the target therapeutic that we had
begun looking at was uh a candidate with
this broad use case um in in uh acute uh
lymphocytic leukemia or all
uh that then um also has an additional
secondary use case and bioprocessing for
the re removal of acrylamides um from
food sources
uh as a headwind to greater benefit
though in this particular um in this
particular therapeutic and that's that
it's uh immunogenic if uh and and so
that limits its usage it's also uh
rapidly degraded that loses its activity
over time
and has a secondary uh neurotoxicity
associated with it with its secondary um
uh uh
enzymatic activity and so there's a real
need for improving the production
improving the enzyme and yet when over
produced it's toxic to e coli by
definition from its uh starvation use
case and uh
and and so there's a real name for
improving also the host to be able to
be capable of producing a highly active
variant
and so i walked through two different
workflows when i was looking at
hydraulics expression expressions first
and foremost i looked at i wanted the
full use case of the unscriptabonic so i
did a
insertion of the gene within the genome
that allows for the scalable stable
expression without an antibiotic
resistance cassette and also enables
onyx-based editing with barcoded's
capacities to be able to track edits
i found that quite powerful i also
wanted to test the plasmid-based
expression system
uh through rapid uh that that allows me
to be able to do rapid cloning uh and
bring all the tools of molecular biology
to bear
with these onyx libraries and um
associates back to being able to make
rapid advancements on that plasmid based
mutagenesis albeit not barcoded so i
want to talk about the hydrologus gene
insertion first
um
so what i want to walk through is that
scale up the concept of scale up that's
happening within just a few months of
time uh so we had this concept of the
the protein of interest to
um to look at uh so it was a
hydraulicist protein that was engineered
to be able to be put onto the genome we
installed it within the inscripted 1022
genome and and then subsequently also
knocked out a native protein that wasn't
interfering with the assay
so we've developed an optimal chassis
for expression within the first two
months
of
from from concept to getting to that
base drain build
so then i i did a further rounds of
production of maximization
for the capacity of the protein given
its toxicity
using utilizing a promoter library that
sat in front of the protein and if
you've
had an opportunity you might want to
check out the gfp
webinar that we've given uh several
months ago that was utilizing a similar
type promoter optimization in front of
gfp uh so here we we were optimizing the
the protein production here you can come
to bear all of the other
gene specific libraries that we talked
about previously doing promoter based
and rbs screening for improved
production as well as changing any
signal sequences or protein tags that
are present and that codon optimization
and the first
several amino acids can be quite
important and you get once it's
installed within the the genome you get
to uh explore all of the protein
function that comes with that
mutagenesis
so then the
kind of then the the real fun starts as
soon as you have that base strain then
you get to cycle through the uh and
engineered genomes to be able to track
the
edits
and that uses again back to that
barcoded capacity of being able to make
variants we can be able to in high
throughput identify the variance uh to
be able better that are uh showing the
improvement
so that's what the workflow looks like
uh we insert the gene we do a onyx
engineering run we take those edited
cells and isolate the individual
variants of interest
and then we um take that towards
phenotyping sequence
the outcome from the
winners and then analyze and learn and
then feed right back into the
engineering cycle
uh so the libraries that then we're
engineering on similar to the um the
yeast story
is we built a number of different
genome-wide libraries such as the
genome-wide knockouts in the
b strain as well as a genome-wide
promoter insertion
so the
upregulating the expression of all
coding sequences one by one per cell the
cell morphology and foley library is a
library that targeted all the cells
associated with anything having to do
with cell morphology or protein folding
uh by knocking out in and
dropping in promoters and truncating all
of those so that we could look
specifically at edits of interest these
would include chaperones proteases
[Music]
z-ring formation etc etc and then we
also have a toxic protein library and
that's scraped from
literature reported variants that seem
to have improved expression
and these are small insertions deletions
or single nucleotide variants that just
generally were reported
what's neat about this is that similar
to that cbh1 story with even one round
of attitem
we're already seeing a number a handful
of hits that are giving greater than two
folds improvements on the
activity so we have an enzymatic uh
activity assay that's of fluorescence
based we did the shallow stamping of
only 440
colonies out of the
12 000 different potential variants so
this is a very shallow sampling and even
with the shallow sampling for first
round we got a greater than two-fold
enhancement
so those uh different uh hits that we're
seeing we have um six that are known for
stress response genes five for actual
cell membrane and stability genes uh
surprisingly six genes were of unknown
function
and then five of the hits were proteases
or
that were knocked out or chaperones that
were up regulated so we had a
a really like impressive number of
interesting hits even on the first
rounds
that showed improvements
um of the protein production
but then i uh transitioned or i wanted
to also you know i'm
now doing the stacked based workflow but
i wanted to see also if we can improve
expression based on the plasmid-based
expression and this workflow is a little
different so here we engineer the cells
first and we have the edited cells i
grew those up and made those competence
um through electroporation and then i
transform in the plasmids that's
compatible with the create architecture
that we have the onyx architecture that
we have and that transformation is uh
then has carrying along with it uh the
expression
cassette of the
gene of interest we isolate that out
into individual colonies phenotype in a
similar way on a plate based reader and
then use sequencing
both on both illumina as well as oxford
nanopore sequencing to identify variants
and then analyze and learn from those
variants
so directly after editing directly off
instruments uh genome-wide knockout
library uh what i'm showing here is the
percent of the library that's observed
so we had 99 percent greater than 99
percent of libraries observed on the
genome-wide knockout genomic promoter in
the cell morphology and protein folding
libraries
after transformation with the plasmids
there's some dropouts uh from you know
you get a reduction of the diversity
that's allowed and a lot of these are
going to be due to the
cell death from the actual knockouts
from actual biological effect
and the other aspect of it is that this
is now 79 of your genome is now
observable for impacting your expression
which is
never before seen so this is just
tremendous to have access to the um to
the to the capability of analyzing
biology in this way
so again we're seeing uh once again that
doing this um now with a extremely small
shallow example again
from the 10 000 different variants that
we could have been screening through um
i've screened through you know just a
couple of plates and replicates uh to be
able to see that induction off of the
plasmids
and
similar to the to the other two stories
is that again i'm seeing about a twofold
enhancement of expression
in a couple of different variants so
those ones at the very top uh one is uh
surrounding the central uh central
metabolism and
another one is associated with uh sugar
lactose metabolism and then another
interesting hit right at the very top is
a gene of unknown function so similarly
we see that kind of story crystallizing
over and over again that we don't know
all of the
capabilities of biology and so we have
to access those unknowns and the best
way that we can do that is by
engineering and tweaking the genome to
be able to perturb it to be able to see
where those novel variants come from you
can see the explosive improvement in
expression i'm really excited to see the
stacked variants as i take it through
the
both the
insertion the genome insertion as well
as the plasmid based uh i think we'll be
looking at
really really high expression on on some
of these proteins
so just in conclusion the onyx is now
supporting that b stream functionality
to improve protein expression uh we have
this rapid workflow that we're kind of
there the the platform's there to help
you and every step along the way from
concept all the way to scale up and that
happens with just a few ftes in just a
couple of months uh even with low depth
of screening we're seeing improvements
on the order of twofold improvements um
we may not you know be hitting that
jackpot on that very first screen but it
sets us up for success when we do
subsequent rounds of editing um taking
that agnostic view that that we're just
looking for optimizing that protein
expression and we also have this
plasmid-based expression with a custom
plasmid to be able to identify
enhancements that are associated with
those genome-wide auditing libraries yet
still being able to utilize that
plasmid-based approach um
for for those users that really like
working on plasmids
so just to wrap up the inscriptonix
works with e coli and and saccharomyces
cerevisiae and a number of customer
strains that are
around those two hosts um we can do
single edits per cell uh both on the
genome itself as well as hydraulic
sequences for e coli it's 100 to 10 000
different um
designs per library
single design per cell
and then uh yeast it's a hundred
up to six thousand and that's insertion
deletion substitution up to 63 base
pairs and all of this you know comes in
a consumable easy to use commit load
consumable kit in um in in about three
weeks
so thank you so much for
um
for for
uh allowing me to present today and i'm
really uh happy to take any questions
um
uh
thank you
thank you dr shepherd for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
so let's get started our first question
here asks
is it possible to perform mutagenesis of
a target gene or operon encoded by a
single copy bac for phosmid in e coli
thanks for the question um that's that's
fantastic um so
we are keenly interested in other
plasmid-based systems such as a uh
on edit uh editing on backs
uh
so
you know i would i would say uh reach
out to an account executive if if you'd
like to chat
about that um so the plasmid-based
system that was used here is a higher
copy plasmid-based expression uh system
uh but definitely um on we we have
ongoing interest as well with back-based
systems
great thank you
next question asks can the same concept
be applied to mammalian or human cells
or cell lines
that's a really good question
so conceptually
you know in theory um
it it can be um
applied uh the enscripta onyx platform
is built specifically uh and currently
for e coli and saccharomyces cerevisiae
work uh and and so highlighted here is
around that uh improvement of the
expression
um
in those hosts uh
yeah thank you
great
next question he said thank you for the
wonderful presentation can the
inscriptive system be used in in vitro
production of sirna
uh
to to improve srna uh another uh
really cool question um so here of
course we we were focused on protein
production uh but i want to say you know
instinctually my gut feeling is
absolutely in a way uh for in vitro
production of srna um typically you
would use polymerases and so forth um
where
you might you know think how would you
apply genome engineering to improve such
a system you could probably focus down
or or look at
uh improved variance for
um for decreasing rnases or so forth and
these are the type of
uh
really good applications for the
inscriptonix technology to be able to
make high throughput edits to microbial
genomes
that could improve those type of
downstream processes
uh that you might want better prd and
and so forth from your final enzyme of
interest um that that's that's exactly
right on to conceptually to
to how how to utilize bestie
onyx technology
great thank you
this next question has a few parts and
it asks how is the plasmid customized
does customization depend on the protein
of interest or is the customization
necessary for co-prop excuse me
co-propagation with the mad 7 nucleus
plasmid
all right cool question um
so
the plasma itself is
customized to be completely compatible
with the plasmid-based uh approach of
that barcoding system that's in e coli
uh so there we had to be thoughtful just
in terms of the origin of replication
that we were using as well as the
antibiotic uh resistance uh that we were
using for it
um so
once we had uh had that capability of of
having it propagated alongside the
plasmid that uh carries the barcode with
it that allows us to be able to access
that barcodes
through the illumina next generation
sequencing approaches
um it does it
propagate along with the mad 7 nucleus
so
this was designed in such a way that
the the the part of the system that
carries the mad 7 nucleus that's
uh fundamental to the onyx approach uh
in in this case we actually uh relieved
it of that parts of the uh
uh of the process so such that the mad
seven uh um enter in the repair
machinery was
absent from these cells that was part of
the plasmid-based choices that we made
for expression uh and open the door to
allow us to be able to introduce the
plasmid without uh disrupting the or or
being disrupted by that mad seven
um
[Music]
nucleus presence
great thank you
next question here you use
fluorescence-based approaches here but
how would i utilize this without
fluorescence-based
phenotyping
i
yeah so the um
the assays presented here uh were all
you know
could all be amenable to
um
to fluorescence or plate reader-based
approaches
uh historically we've also used
high-throughput mass spec for asean um
and and that can also be applied uh
within the the approaches taken here
so there we would be screening for a
production of
small molecules
during the assay uh so fluorescence
gives you
you know a pretty straightforward and
accessible readout on phenotyping
uh
and of course is amenable to plate based
and so when you have assays
that are capable of even through tags um
looking at protein expression or
enzymatic activity through fluorescence
uh the phenotyping there are many uh
approaches where the phenotyping can be
uh
done in
in very high throughputs
that being said even as you saw with uh
with shallow sampling we were seeing you
know some pretty nice hits coming
through
and so even
a workflow then where you know it might
be a lower throughput workflow um you
can still imagine that you're going to
see some some hits in a in a in a screen
a load screening a based approach the
other approach that i didn't talk much
about is a selectors-based approach and
a lot of enzymatic um activities can be
converted into a selectors-based
approach uh with some genome engineering
uh involved and so that's something to
be thoughtful
as well about that really opens the
capacity of exploring all of the
variants
in a selector's workflow
great
next question is this webinar or slides
going to be available for download
uh
yes i i i believe that uh the webinar
will be available for uh downloads um
fairly soon
or watching online again
awesome next question here how could i
get some of your yeast libraries or
clones for verification purposes
uh interesting question um
so
for for now for uh
it if of interest for
um for reaching out for for any project
ideas that you might have uh i might
point you towards contacting an account
a representative or an account
representative might be in touch but um
but that can help to
uh identify if there's an interest uh
for
projects of of specific interest or
purpose uh
and and then also um yeah just just
getting in touch uh
with us if you have some types of of
those questions that's great
great we have time for a few more
questions here so we'll continue on
are the improvements you're seeing with
your edits generally helping protein
expression or are they specific to the
protein
um
this is a good question uh we have an
interest in exploration of this question
as well and i think the plasmid based
approach becomes amenable to be able to
test in high throughput
so
the answer here is going to be
a little murky because i only showed
data for one particular protein or one
particular enzyme in e coli but now with
uh with that opportunity to be able to
screen in in high throughputs uh genome
engineering
um that would
allow um
us to be able to observe with multiple
different proteins if it's a general if
if the
modifications have general utility of
plasmids across the board our proteins
across the border
um
the focus down on some sometimes that's
going to be the case and other times as
you're screening uh through
what we would uh presumably find is that
other edits are
specific to an individual protein and
the activity of the individual protein
so i think the enscript onyx platform
gives us a unique capacity to be able to
discover uh if it's a general phenomenon
versus a specific phenomenon on
on proteins and and really it takes that
iterative workflow to be able to
discover
specific host variants that can really
you know
hit the ball out of the park in terms of
expression of any given specific protein
is is the way that i look at it
it looks like we have time for one more
question so we'll wrap up here what type
of improvement would you expect had you
screened all the edits and why did you
only screen just a few hundred in the
e-coli
yeah we've often seen this a good
question so
when when proteins are
uh expressed when when you create
variance sorry when you create variants
with the inscriptonics platform uh
because of the high throughput nature of
it you're routinely generating libraries
of greater than 10 000 different
variants that might have
a specific impact on the expression
profile
and so one philosophy might have that
you would like to be able to see what
every
variant in that pool all 10 000 uh what
what the change in capacity is
but really what we've found over and
over again is that time is better spent
by doing a shallow sampling and with
with a fairly low screening and then
stacking on top of your hits and so we
saw that with like the cbh1 uh yi story
that's uh that
we
um
um for sure i saw like this you know
four-fold improvement once we're
stacking on top of uh with a shallow
sampling and we want to port that over
and do that with the b strain as well
because we think that the same
philosophy you know we've seen that with
lysine production small molecule
production and we've seen that with uh
tolerance to growth inhibitors where uh
shallow screening
[Music]
several colonies and then stacking on
top of those adds richness to the
library uh well beyond what what we
would get if we spent all of the same
amount of time or all of our time trying
to screen through all 10 000 different
variants
great and we got one more question that
just popped into the chat that we have
time to answer real quick
will you introduce case strain
engineering
uh fantastic questions so k strain
engineering is uh sweet spot and
definitely supported um
we've we've been doing that approach
we've been working with mg1655
uh we're definitely ready with k-string
engineering as as much as as b strain
engineering
fantastic well thank you again dr
shepherd for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor in
scripta for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand and labyrinths will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time take care everyone goodbye
you